Damien Edwards here from Microsoft nice
to be back in Australia to talk to you
all about asp.net Core 2 which just came
out what yesterday I think our time if
you're in my workshop the last two days
I may have snuck you the bits a little
early but that's fine they were they
were privileged people they came and
learnt about all the great stuff and I'm
going to talk to you about the next 59
minutes or so and we'll talk about some
of that stuff now as well how many
people are already using a spoon 8 core
Wow that's awesome
all right fantastic well hopefully
there's some stuff here that you see is
an improvement and hopefully where we
can address things that maybe are still
bugging you about a spinet core but
hopefully you're getting a lot of
success with it as well so good to see
I'm at the end I hope to have little bit
of time for questions because usually
people have plenty of questions to ask
about a speed on that core it's still
fairly new but we'll see how we go so a
quick recap of how we got to where we
are now because the timeline of asp.net
core is a little undulating and a little
interesting so we can all think back to
when it was still called a screen f5 and
that DNX thing and that's actually the
second name we had a different name
before that but I'm not I'm not going to
go there back that far I'll just go back
to when we were doing beaters which was
2015 so we're only talking two years ago
two and a half years ago but then by the
end of that year we released we renamed
a spinnaker one oh we released an RC in
November but we also told you that we
were going to change everything
after the RC so sorry about that and
then in February three short months
later we released net core now that we
had a dotnet core and we kind of rolled
a spin net core into that entire release
we call that our c2 and then we told you
that we were going to change all the
tooling so project Jason was kind of
still there and RC too but then we said
don't worry about that that's going to
go away we're gonna reinvent Sears proj
so okay so we're not quite 100 yep then
we released a 1o in June last year so
that's not far it's only what 1415
months ago but we didn't release any
tooling
right there was still a preview tooling
it was vs 2015 it wasn't the best
tooling experience but anyway the run
time and a spinet core was out so you
could use it then we did a 1.1 release
of just the run time a full five six
months later but we still really hadn't
we haven't got anywhere close to getting
the tooling to be good enough to call
the 100 yet so I think that was the vs
2017 preview before we released our TM
so there was a version of now of the
sears proj tools but they you know they
weren't great so it was still
recommended that you use the project
decent tools because they were the only
ones in a supportive version of vs so
you know we're already like into our
first minor release of the run time and
we still don't really have a good
tooling story then we actually released
what we consider to be our first real
one oh so in release neck or SD k1o in
march this year so that was really not a
long time ago at all along with Visual
Studio 2017 okay now so we had a spinet
core and dot neck or 1.1 dot something
by that point some patch level and then
we finally had a one-hour version of the
tools so things were finally looking up
so we saw a lot of customers wait until
this point before they really jumped on
board a speed on their core for good
reason right I mean they kind of just
went well you know what this is all too
much yeah I'll keep a side eye on this
but I'm not gonna really get in there
and start using it for real and so you
can give me a supported version of
Visual Studio and a fairly good tooling
experience to do so so that was good and
then at the same time we announce that
this better version of.net come was
going to come along but that standard or
this nice new contract that was going to
bring back all the api's that you're all
telling us that you wanted and so even
if you thought 100 was a good start but
you really thought - oh is that the
beginning of the journey because that's
when all the api's would come back you
may have still been holding out and then
finally only a few months after the one
oh really we now have a - oh so the
timeline kind of accelerated the ones
once we had a whole bunch of Chernov
ously before a spinet 5 leading up to
that it was actually a couple of year
effort and then everything kind of went
crazy for a couple years and then we're
landed where we here where we are right
now
so we're one day into
nelq or two and a spoon 8-core - we're
at vs 2017 15.3 we would have called
that update three last year but now
we're calling it 15.3 whatever I know if
it's better people like 15 three better
than update three I don't know
I'm here I people give me both opinions
but we're in a good state I think we're
in a really good really good place and
dotnet core 2 brings along a lot of
great features and fixes a lot of stuff
so hopefully you're not too confused
anymore
now that we're out to where we can kind
of forget about everything that came
before it and we can just focus on the
path forward the Taurus cycle though
it's it's worth calling out as you can
see was fairly short and was fairly
focused on some foundational issues you
know one missing a crap-ton of api is
made it very difficult for people to
grasp moving their apps or starting new
apps on their core and so we fixed that
to a large extent with dotnet standard -
- the tooling still wasn't particularly
great in the VF 2017 story new CS
progeny new gap new paradigms and it
just hadn't had a lot of time to bake
and so the two-hour version that tooling
now is much much better and I'll show
you some of the improvements underneath
there as well things like startup time
for the application what we call the
inner loop performance this is when you
know what you as developers do more than
ten times a day we classify as in a loop
there's still a lot of work we have to
do to make that inner loop experience
really as fast as we want to be but
we've made some really good improvements
from the 102 the - Oh
releases so less about features in 200
I'm going to show you a bunch of
features and a lot more about fixing
some of these foundational issues which
is why the timeline from the last sort
of big 100 release has been so short all
right so the first one we talked about
was dotnet standard - who here has been
confused by dotnet standard at some
point okay good well not good but good
and who was confused by PC ELLs and
portable class libraries before that
okay less people but we now here in our
experience not as many people had been
exposed to PC ELLs so that's not unusual
whereas we've been blasting dotnet
standard like from the mountain top for
the last year now and
it can be a little difficult to explain
so just before I jump into this and let
me just quickly reiterate Don that
standard is not something that you can
run on it's not a platform it is not a
flavor of net as handsome and likes to
talk about the different flavors of net
it is a target that you can compile
against okay that you can reference and
then it is a promise that once you've
done that the thing that you've built
will run on flavors of dotnet that honor
or adhere to or are compliant with the
version of.net standard that you
targeted okay it's very much like saying
I'm gonna program this API against this
I Danian interface alright and then you
can give me any class that implements I
damien and i'll be able to use that that
make sense it's very much like that okay
and so in dotnet standard two we added I
think it was I've seen different numbers
it's either nearly 15,000 or just over
15,000 it's a crap ton of new API it's
had more than doubled the API surface of
dotnet standard from 1.6 which was the
previous version the one that we shipped
with dotnet core 100k most of those came
nearly all of them came from dotnet
framework so what we effectively did is
we said let's look at salmon because
newsflash we bought xamarin last year
let's look at xamarin let's look at net
framework and let's look at dotnet core
and let's look at the overlap of those
API sets well it turns out xamarin
and.net framework have many many many
more api in their core and lots and lots
of code out there that runs on those two
things so let's use that intersection as
a basis because frankly there was kind
of nothing in dotnet core so that was
kind of pointless so let's look at
dotnet framework examine take that Union
see what falls out and let's add all
that to dotnet standard well whatever
makes sense anyway and then we went
through a review process it was all up
on github you could follow along some of
the api's were tweaked along the way and
then we landed with dotnet standard to
the short story means most of the API is
that were common have now come back and
you can just use them in your darkness
standard library to your class libraries
which also means you can use them on
dotnet core too which is great it means
that you can reference a whole bunch of
packages that are already on NuGet
without them having to be recompiled
which is really really cool it does mean
that if you're running on
framework the minimum version of.net
framework that you need to have now to
be dotnet standard to compliant is high
it's higher than it was before because
don't let standard 1x supported lower
versions are done their framework so
we're talking about done their framework
for six one which I'm hoping most people
here are at least on for six one there's
only one version lower than that that's
officially supported which is four five
two but please be on for six one or
above that would be great as a Marine
dotnet core to I'm like mono five unity
all support dotnet standard to libraries
okay so you can write down a standard
two libraries you can consume to
understand or to libraries and use them
on these flavors or these platforms of
dotnet any you WP developers one
gentleman down the back well for you sir
don't net standard two will be coming to
a you WP project near you in rs3 alright
which i think is called the what the
autumn creators the fall
I don't care stupid name okay the thing
that's coming out later this year
alright because we're in the southern
hemisphere so falls not gonna be your
autumns not gonna be here them so it's
coming
you can't I get to understand it too and
be confident that you're going to get a
good future ahead don't it stand it
won't change much I think from now on
we're not going to see a rave have done
distended every year because if we do
that all these platforms are going to
become a lot more fractured again right
Dante framework doesn't ship any quicker
than it used to is you've probably
noticed and so if we start adding api's
and releasing your dot nests and a two
point one you don't need frameworks
that's gonna get left behind the game
and your uwp stuff with ships and
windows will get left even further
behind okay so we really don't want to
do that we want to build a solid
foundation which is what we have now and
then build ancillary or satellite
packages what we call herbs add a band
not in the standard that you could
consume from anywhere because they're
based on the standing all right now
there is this compact shim thing to I
don't really talk about it too much but
one of the things that they standard to
enables in the tooling is that if you're
seeing a dotnet core to project you can
actually reference packages and dll's
that were compiled against dotnet
framework okay even though you're gonna
run them on Linux fine eight core two
and the compiler will just happily let
you yep it's all good I'll let you
compile that now will they run
they might it all depends on what that
assembly or that package that you've
referenced actually does at runtime
right what does it actually reference if
it references and only calls parts of
the dotnet of dotnet framework that are
in dotnet standard - it works it just
works just fine
as soon as you hit any part of the API
surface that is not in dotnet standard -
it will explode when you try and run it
on dotnet core - because that API isn't
there okay so if you have a library that
tries to load something in WPF or system
web or WCF or system don't work flow or
whatever thing else is in there that's
in framework but it's not in core then
you won't be able to consume that in.net
core - but everything else you can and I
think the figures the dotnet team put
out say that about
I think it's 70 percent or so of all the
packages on new georg fall within this
this scope of yes you can reference them
and they will run happily on dotnet core
- because they fall within the scope of
api's that are included in dotnet
standard - okay that's pretty cool
alright who is currently running a spoon
8 core on.net framework rather than
running it on dotnet core ok so that's
about a quarter maybe a fifth of the
room so we had a little hiccup when we
shipped to a preview one and we had to
very very late cut support for dotnet
framework and then some stuff happened
and now it's back so it's back in
preview - and now to our rtm which is
great that's supported because of this
whole dotnet standard - stuff right we
can target dotnet standard - as
framework developers in the a speed on
that core team and 99.9 percent of the
time that just means our stuff works and
then there's some very edgy
circumstances where we have to
explicitly code for dotnet core - or.net
framework and there are some aspects of
the asp.net core to our experience which
I'm going to show you
they're only work when you're on dotnet
core because they just rely on features
that we've been able to add at the
platform level in.net core that don't
exist in dotnet framework and I'll talk
about those in a minute when I talk
about those improvements as I mentioned
before the minimum version now is four
six one so if you're using asp.net core
and you're running on dotnet framework
you want to go to a spinet core - you
will have to go up to dotnet framework
four six one which I hope you're on
already or newer
okay on you I think is up to four seven
one or something now so it's good stuff
alright so we have new project templates
the CLI the Dantas CLI and the V is 20
is everything now share the same project
templates which is great so you can nor
throw a set of project templates and
it's all fully customizable some great
articles but how to do this you can
deliver them via NuGet packages and then
you can have them show up in both the
CLI and in vs if you write a vs
extension what have we got new into
we're out of the box we've got spire
templates for angular react and react
and redux that's using the asp.net is
p.net course spa services framework
Steve Sanderson from the ACP net team
we'll be doing a talk on that I think
later this week might be today so if
you're using any power frameworks with a
speed on that core please go and check
that out we now have a Razer pages which
is the new page based framework built
into MVC which I'll have a separate talk
on after this one we have off support
for Asia b2c ok that's the business to
consumer or Asia b2c authentication
service out of the box to factor off now
built in using off indicator wraps
rather than using SMS which is old and
stinky and we have a much simplified
project creation experience in vs than
what we did before which I'll show off
in fact let's do that right now so let's
go over to V s this is V s 2017 15.3
freshly updated over hotel Wi-Fi a
couple of days ago which took a while if
I go in here you'll see now that rather
than having two entries freeze banette
call like we used to
we simply have one right every spinet
core web application and it's at the top
we've got a lot of feedback that people
were confused and we had to here once it
done that framework and one said net
core and a lot of people were creating
projects on the wrong thing so now it's
more like the old one a spinette dialog
and hopefully the intent is in the
future we'll merge these two together as
well so we spin air can guess what to
get back to this one a spur net dialogue
and you just choose what you want and
you'll spit out the right project so let
me start Annie's been on a core project
and we've got a couple of new things in
here so this is where I pick whether I
want to run on dotnet core I don't know
framework now okay yes and I know in the
previous screen there's that
anachronistic drop-down in the top left
hand corner that says dotnet framework
versions that's just an unfortunate
throwback
from vs 2010 it's still there we can't
really do much about it hopefully it'll
disappear in a future version but this
is where you select whether you want
dotnet core I don't know framework
obviously you can do side by side so
once you've installed a speed on that
core or dotnet core - I should say which
includes a spinet core - all this stuff
will just show up okay and one oh and
one one we're already in the box and vs
and we add two oh if I go back to one
one you'll see that I don't have as many
templates and if I go to - oh I have all
these wonderful new templates so my web
application template is now built using
razor pages and if I prefer I can
continue to build HTML generating
eastern air core applications using
separated model views and controllers
but frankly I much prefer Razer pages
and then we have these new angular react
and react jes Redux templates when it
comes to auth we have quite a few more
options in here the default is still no
orth obviously but if you want to do
individual off the default is still
store it inside the application but you
can now say hey I want to go off and use
Azure ad b2c to delegate or my off to
the cloud during file new which is kind
of nice and we still have the same
support we had before for a single log
and multi old cloud authentication using
Microsoft Active Directory in Azure or
if you're just doing internet
applications behind is you can continue
to use Windows off the same way you have
been before so that's pretty cool so I'm
going to pick individual off and store
those accounts in the application I'm
going to go ahead and create that
project alright so when I create the
project you'll notice that thing was had
a little like warning triangle on it for
a moment because when you create a
project a new get restore takes place
okay if we go and have a look in here we
can see in my new get dependencies it's
a little simplified from what it was in
1x and I'll talk a little bit more about
this in a moment but I want to talk a
little bit about some of the tooling
improvements we've made to improve this
sort of this inner loop and this file
new experience if I come to the command
line I'm gonna do the same thing I did
up there but I'll do it in the command
line hope that my mouse doesn't
disappear off the lectern here so if I
do net new you see all the templates
down here that you've probably seen
before lots lots and lots lots lots of
templates she can you see that pretty
much
I'll do dotnet new razor to create
myself the same thing I just created in
NBS so that was pretty quick so it says
that Newgate took two seconds to restore
my new project which isn't too bad
alright and if I do dotnet restore again
it like but it practically was instant
so I said 50 0.99 milliseconds for the
first restore on 40 1.28 for the second
now why is there - does anyone ever
wondered why does NuGet always say it's
doing two restores when you do a dotnet
core project with tools well it's
because you have tools if you go into
your CS proj file see these two
different types of reference you have a
package reference and you have a dotnet
CLI tool reference these are called
project tools and these are just normal
packages nuget runs those two restores
in parallel all right which is why you
get two timings at the bottom just so
you know if you've ever wondered why
there was two there right so Newgate
does caching now so when you restore if
nothing has changed that would affect
the new get graph in between restore
operations it's basically free as you
can see here all right it basically
happens instantly and that's really
important because vs does implicit
restores now and dotnet new doesn't
implicit restore so we want to make sure
that if you don't need to do a restore
because they're quite expensive you
don't have to do it so that's good the
second thing that new new get did is
they invented a feature called the new
get full back folder well watch then you
get full back folder well everyone knows
where your new get packages get restored
to you right if I go to my user profile
and I actually put eight percent at the
beginning than a dollar sign going to
new get go into packages this is where
all my new get packages get restored to
by default on this machine okay it goes
into my user profile they get reused for
all my projects life is good but if I'm
a first-time user if I'm restoring a new
thing I haven't restored before or I
downloaded a spinet core two and I
install it we don't want you to have to
download the Internet to put it in here
the first time you create a project that
kind of sucks right
or you install it you turn off your
Wi-Fi you get on an aeroplane and then
you can't create projects cuz you have
no new get support so in the past we
would pre install a feed somewhere on
your machine that you couldn't see and
then first time it would have to copy
all of that stuff out of the feed into
this location into your restore location
and if you don't have a lovely fast SSD
like I do
that can take quite a long amount of
time all right it's a lot of file i/o so
there's a new feature in new get called
then you get fallback folder and we
install one of those for you as part of
installing net so in my program files
folder in my dot net home under SDK I've
got this new folder down here new get
fallback folder and it's immutable it's
in Program Files you need to be an
administrator to change it all right
it's read-only so when you restore now
new get will treat this as if it was
already part of your new get restore
location okay which means that if it's
in here no file i/o has to take place at
all we don't have to get it from the
internet or check and we don't have to
copy it from a local feed into your
restore location it's just there and
then when the application runs it runs
out of here okay anything that was
already in here dotnet core knows how to
load assemblies that are in here and
they'll just get loaded from here so
that's why it's one of the reasons we've
been able to make dotnet new and then
sort of that getting started experience
so much quicker thanks to the good work
from the nougat team okay what else is
good so we've got two file new and then
we have a looked at the content yes
let's have a talk about what's new in
the content so in the first templates we
shipped in eight-minute core one and one
one everything was kind of in the
template right we didn't opinion we
didn't have any opinions on how anything
should be in the framework at all you
wanted logging you had to write code to
add logging you wanted a Diagnostics
page you had to add code to do it not
Diagnostics page you want a
configuration there was no configuration
baked into the framework you had to add
a package you had to new up a
configuration object in your startup
file and you would use that okay so we
had all these little subsystems and then
it was up to you to compose them
together the way you wanted it sounds
great you only pay for what you get it
just meant that the templates we're
fairly complicated because you had to do
quite a lot just to get going to get
hello world in an idiomatic fashion you
needed a lot of code so what we did is
we took those opinionated idiomatic
style sort of base templates and they're
not really templates it's like what
infrastructure do I need to get a basic
functional app going and we put them
into a new API web host create default
builder okay web host is a static
factory class that essentially gives me
instances of the I web host builder
interface which we had in one
which is the thing that you use to boot
a spinet call all right that's where you
compose the host and everything and then
you call run and that's what starts up a
spinet core in your application call
start up that CS and then you're off to
the races so we have a nice compact way
of doing that now all your a spin air
core packages are now reference by
default when you're under core through
one single reference okay the a speed on
there chord are all which means you have
a single version number to reason about
that covers all of a spinet core so you
get less of that version mismatch he'll
that you can get with new get when you
start having lots and lots of packages
and it also means you don't have to find
packages to get api's they're just there
we automated them defaulted
configuration and loggers as part of
this default experience and then we put
them in DI so that you can now just get
the default configuration object out of
the ioc container anywhere in your
application and you can configure any
logger providers that you might have had
in DI rather than adding them separately
as a separate concern which can be quite
annoying if you have a very complicated
logging provider that relies on services
that come out of di ok or digitally nice
if the DI container could activate that
for you that's what it does now lastly
or the two last things we did in one one
I don't know if anyone ever played with
it or saw the demo the console logger
provider enabled you to filter what logs
would go to the console based on config
files while the application was running
ok so you could run the application as
the developer see a bunch of log
messages open up your settings file
change it and save it and then without
restarting your app those log messages
would be filtered for the next request
we've expanded that capability to the
entire logging subsystem so now any
logger provider okay whether it's a
third party logger provider or one that
we ship gets the benefit of config
driven logging straight out of the box
and then lastly we enable DI scope
validation by default but only when
you're in development because it will
break your applications guaranteed so DI
scope validation is a feature of our ioc
container that will throw an exception
if it determines that you have
registered two dependent types with
mismatching scopes and the reason that's
important is that if you do it
incorrectly you can very very easily
introduce leaks into your application
and more importantly security issues
into your application
okay if you register a singleton object
that depends on a scoped object the
singleton will activate the scoped
object once and it will live for the
life of the application and then anyone
else who wants it will get the singleton
version that's not good
all right and so this is now turned on
by default when you're in development
and if you miss configure your di
container it will just throw now if you
don't fix it and you deploy to
production
it'll just happily go off and keep
running we didn't make it throw in any
environment other than development we
thought that was just a little bit too
draconian but we're trying to protect
you from yourself and to be fair I say
yourselves we did it ourselves in MVC
and we had to ship a security update to
one oh because we found that we'd done
something wrong it's very easy to get
wrong publishers in the startup time so
the dotnet core assemblies are now all
and the a spinet core assemblies are now
all included in a very special secret
folder hidden away as party vendor Cora
installation which I'll talk about and
show in a minute called the runtime
store and it sounds an awful lot in
characteristics like the GAC but it's
not the GAC it's much better than the
GAC I call it the new GAC in new GAC
but they don't like me calling it that
because the GAC has a lot of negative
connotations but it is better than the
GAC so all the things that you put into
the runtime store which includes all of
a spinet core and any framework core and
all the stuff that we depend on it gets
pre jittered so that your application
startup time is better so that's good
and you don't have to publish them with
your application because they're already
in the runtime store they're part of
the.net core installation ok so now when
you publish up your applications they're
much much much smaller by default lastly
the razor view compilation is turned on
by default which also drastically
reduces the size if your the output of
your published app and improve startup
time so we'll have a look at those
things now the runtime store is
exclusive to dotnet core it's not a
feature of dotnet framework it is
something we've only been able to add in
to dotnet core so let's have a look at
all those things that I just talked
about so this is what my new project
file looks like for a razor pages app
that has been configured with off ok so
I have this Microsoft that a spinet
chord are all packaged which quite
literally includes
everything that the a spent on that core
team and the EF core team and the
related team ship and everything that we
depend on so if we have a Redis provider
for our distributed cash abstraction
then we ship Stack Exchange dot
registers package included inside this
meta package ok the sequel Lite package
is included in here a bunch of other
stuff is included in here because we
include we light up on top of Asia but
you only have to worry about that one
version number so when we patch any of
those things this will go to 201 and
then 202 and then when we do a minor
release it'll go to 2.1 okay and you
only have to think about one thing right
now these other things here aren't
runtime these are all to do with tooling
which is why they're separate and that's
why they're marked as private assets all
that means they don't get deployed with
your app all right and then this section
down here as I said before are your
project tools alright so these are the
things that give you dotnet EF and net
user secrets and dotnet a spinette
scaffold at the command line okay so
much much simplified package graph which
is nice to see if I go into my program
main if you think back to what this
looked like and one one we've now got
this split we've got the program main
that you would typically see in a
console app which calls out to this
build web host dot run method well why
are they split this pattern here of
having a method that returns an eye web
host for your application hanging off
your program class is so that the
command-line tools can find this without
having to enter and start up your
application through program main all
right so things like dotnet EF the
command-line tool that you run to run
migrations it actually has to start your
application to load your configuration
to initialize your DB context from di in
order to run migrations and to add
migrations ok it needs to know about
your database to do that and so it uses
this hook ok the important thing in here
is this calling out to this new method
web host create default builder ok and
this is the one I talked about that
defaults a whole bunch of the stuff
around config and logging and using
kestrel and lighting up behind IES and
etc etc etc for you by default now you
can still customize it so we still have
all the same methods hanging off here
that we did before there's this this
returns an eye web host builders the
exact same API we had in one-one and so
all the same methods
configuration that was there before is
still here and we've got a couple of new
ones as well now the configuration is
set up for you automatically as part of
this there's a configure out
configuration method here that you can
use to add configuration providers
alright maybe you've written a custom
conflict provider that load stuff out of
I don't know a database or a different
file format okay
you can add that very early in the
pipeline by doing that here or perhaps
you need to configure your logging very
early in the pipeline and have it work
along with the default logging you can
do that here as well now but as I said
before by default we now default a whole
bunch of this stuff for you and you know
the app works pretty well straight out
of the box if we go over to startup to
CS a couple of changes here we now
accept our configuration in the
constructor of startup because remember
I said my configuration is now in the DI
container because we set it up during
the previous file okay when I call
create default web host build up and put
my configuration in DI for me so I now
have that here I stamp that onto my
property and then I go and do what I
normally did I do configure services and
I do configure to configure my HTTP
pipeline now these are a little cleaner
because I don't have to configure
logging here anymore I used to have to
have all my login configuration codes
set up in the configure method that's
now all done as part of the DI container
and it's done by default as part of that
create default web host builder so I
don't need to worry about that okay
nicey-nice I'm going to run this and
we'll see some of this default logging
stuff in action so remember this was a
RZR pages application with
authentication turned on by default I'm
sorry with our individual off turned on
because I selected it not by default all
right so there's my application running
if I come over to back to vs over here
and I view my output window you can see
that it makes a lot of me because it's
not like there it is that I've got all
the logs coming from the running
application under debug now being pumped
out to an output source over here which
is kind of nice to get this experience
before you had to run from the command
line or you had to choose kestrel as
your as your launch target rather than
being behind I yes so that's nice also
note that it does the job of pre fixing
it so that if you've got more than one
application running and you've attached
to the
I'm using the debugger you can
differentiate which project is giving
you which log which is kind of nice but
it is just a flat list of you know
information you know it's useful don't
get me wrong
but it would be not much nicer if we had
a richer more structured logging
experience going on here and luckily we
do it's enabled by default so if I
scroll up here you've seen this thing
over here right the new diagnostic tools
window that's been in the debug
experience for three years 2017 well
it's gone through a little bit of
revision since we're 2017 came out and
you may have noticed this application
insights events summary down here that
shows up now and we can see that it
actually has some events being populated
well up on the toolbar there's an
application insights button which has
the same number written next to it so if
I click on that it brings up the
application inside search experience
which as you can see is populated with
all of the data that application
insights has captured from this
application now what does get captured
in a spinnaker app by default in vs well
every request gets tracked you can see
that up here because it says I made 28
requests and you can see them here being
marked with a little globe it also
captures all log information so anytime
that you call out to ilogger in your
application it'll get mapped to a trace
in application insights anytime we call
out to I log because all of a spinet
core itself and entity framework or also
uses the AIA logger interface that will
get caught in here as well so you can
see that there are parts of a spinette
core logging information over here as
part of these requests to go through but
furthermore as I mentioned before you
can change what's going on here on the
fly so I can open up my app settings
development JSON file which controls the
configuration of my app when I'm in the
development environment which is what
I'm doing here obviously and you can see
that we defaulted the verbosity level
for certain log sources out of the box
so we set default to debug so all of
your messages if you do them a debug or
lower will come through okay but for
system and Microsoft we set that to
information now if you think it's too
noisy
you could set these to error okay
actually type error correctly come back
here and hit f5 and now if I go back to
my opinion
search and hit search now it was 89
before if I hit search this time note
that my most recent ones now are just
requests all those trace messages have
gone because I dialed down the verbosity
of the Microsoft logs or you might be
trying to debug something from that you
suspect it's one of our problems or
something that we did wrong so you could
turn Microsoft up to trace okay then we
could come back here I could hit f5 a
couple of times on my application
research and now I've got a hundred and
forty nine messages in trace and I'm
getting basically every single message
that a spread on their call logs under
the covers for you okay and if I was
making sequel queries through EF I would
see all those show up in here as well
now this is a structured logging system
so I can click on any one of these and
you can see all the properties are over
here available to you maintain their
structure you can search for the
properties you can add them to the
current filter okay or you can just come
up to the search box and type for
anything that you think is anywhere in
any of this database of log information
and app insights will find it for you
now this is all completely local none of
this is using app insights in Asia this
is just an experience that lives in the
debugger in Visual Studio okay so you
don't have to worry about signing up for
anything in Asia or any of that type of
jazz if that if you if you're worried
about that all right
again enabled by default when you use vs
2017 out-of-the-box okay let's publish
this application have a look at its
output let me stop bolt tapping find the
right one there it is so obviously I've
just been running out of the app
directly here let me publish the
application I'll just use vs I'll say
I'm going to publish to a folder yep
defaults is fine I'll hit publish it's
going to build first now it's doing
publish blah blah blah publish publish
publish running running running
publisher succeeded okay let's go and
look at the output so that we enter bin
it went into release because published
by default is a release output publish
output so here is the output of my
application for a speed net core -
there's a whole bunch of things missing
you might be thinking if you've ever
looked at the publish output if you're a
spinet core 1x app this should look
different to you now first thing you
might notice is that by default we're
getting these pre-compiled views
assemblies and that's because we enable
MVC view precompilation by default now
in the a spinnaker SDK that also removes
all serious HTML files from your output
because once there precompiled you don't
need them anymore
all right they're not going to do you
any good to have them in the output
because we don't read them if we find
matching ones in the pre compiled folder
so we just in the pic compiled assembly
so we just remove them ok saves you a
whole bunch of space we also remove the
refs folder anyone ever seen the refs
folder in the output of their published
out ok
they're the reference assemblies that
are required when we run time compile
your razor files well we're not doing
that anymore so we can delete those as
well that saves you another three mega
so and then the biggest thing is none of
the asp.net assemblies are there the
only assemblies that are here are the
ones that came from your app ok web
application 29 and it's pre compiled
views everything else dotnet core a
speed on that core and any framework
Microsoft the extensions anything else
that you've used in that Microsoft dot a
speed a chord all package is not in here
it's all hidden away in the magical
runtime store that I talked about before
so how big is have published app now so
it's under three megabytes this is an a
razor Pages app with about four page
it's actually a lot more than four pages
about 20 pages because this one has off
so it has the full earth experience that
you've seen I'll show you a little bit
more of that in a minute
but it's under three megabytes now okay
not bad at all well how fast does it
start up after I've published it well
let's go and try that so I'm going to go
down the command line we'll clear this
out I'm going to change to that
directory so here I am in the publish
output of the thing I just ran okay well
I just published show you and I will
execute it now I can't do dotnet run
dotnet run is the developer command okay
it compiles your app if it needs to and
then it boots it for development mode I
just want to run the app directly so I'm
just gonna run web application as a
twenty nine took the DLL right boom
started alright you saw how quick that
was control see started alright so it's
running on localhost five thousand now
the time for the web server to start
listening is a good measurement but it's
not the only one we really care about if
we're serving HTML there's a lot of
stuff that happens on the first request
in asp.net core di as lazy lazily
initiated NBC is lazily initiated so we
need to really hit it with a request to
appreciate how fast it may or may not be
so if I go and hit low
will host five thousand one one that
stun right so that started in what I
couldn't even get to one one thousand
right so it's much much much much
quicker to start up now than it was in a
spirit core 1x because of all these
optimizations that we made all right and
I challenge you go off laughter you've
converted your app time your current a
spinet core 1x app doing those things I
just did upgrade it to 200 and then time
it doing the same things again and then
tweet back at me what improvement you
got and if you didn't get an improvement
or gumpa bit it was worse let me know
that too and we'll try and figure out
why so the last reason why this is so
much faster now
what's because of that run time story I
talked about so there is a new command
that you can use to control that look
that doesn't look good let's go back to
thee so this is not net store command
which I have to pass help to and this
one
enables you to put things in this
optimize store in a central location on
a machine so that you don't have to
deploy them with the application ok and
so they get optimized and pre engined or
pre cross change as we call it now so
you don't have to pay as much it cost on
startup so where is this store where is
this magical location this new GAC don't
call it that
because I'll get in trouble so it's
under Program Files net store so if you
use our default installers so on Windows
it'll go here on Mac it goes into
whatever the Mac path is and if you're
on Linux and you use like apt-get or
whatever it goes into wherever we do it
there if you download a zip or a tarball
it's included in that ok if you get the
full one and there are separate zip and
tarballs for those of you who really
like finally honing your install for
the.net core runtime and the asp.net
core runtime store alright then you just
like compose them together and you get
full control but what's in here well
there's my dotnet XE and in the store
folder I have a bit nostalgia ok this is
the store for things that are targeting
net core app - oh darn air core - and
then look it looks like packages right
basically looks like packages it looks
like the folder layout of a new get
application if I jump into a spinet core
there's a version number there's a lib
folder and that standard - and then
there's my DLL alright and so dotnet
core - knows how to load stuff out of
here if it exists but and this is where
it's better than the GAC
if you have this DLL in your bin folder
it'll load it from your bin folder it
doesn't care what version it is it
doesn't say all but the one in the store
is the same version so I'll load that
just says no if you deployed it it wins
all right those of you have ever dealt
with the GAC and have had to diagnose
why it is your assembly and your bin
folder is not being loaded it's because
something in the GAC has taken it over
all right you I'm hopefully you're very
happy to hear that that's the case all
right so bin always wins on dotnet core
all right but we do get the benefits of
a central location where it's optimized
alright so let's talk about some little
features that we've added I've just
talked about very underlying things and
but stuff to do with ice to do with the
startup cycle what about features so we
have some small ones as I said it was a
fairly small release milestone I hosted
service who does background work in the
race banette core apps like who starts
up a background thread to do anything
listen to a RabbitMQ cue or live monitor
a file okay a couple of things come up
if you want to have that activated by
the dependency injection system by the
container which is what you really want
right and then you want to be notified
when the app is starting and then when
it's shutting down it's a little hard to
do today so we now have a service
interface that's in the box by default
that you can implement and then we
automatically discover these out of the
DI container and we activate them for
you we call start on them when we call
stop on them and it's as simple as that
okay in the future we see this becoming
the very foundation of that web host
class that whole idea of having program
main start up a host and say run is foul
is all built on this idea the web
servers in the future will probably
implement a hosted service because all
the server is in a spinner core is
something in the container that gets
activated after it's configured it says
go and then starts listening and
dispatching requests alright the
container doesn't know any different
doesn't care and the host doesn't know
any different it doesn't care just wants
things to call start on and then when
someone shuts down the host it wants
things to call stop 1 ok so if you're
doing any type of health monitoring or
doing message bus q1e type of receiving
and stuff this is a good candidate and
we will ship implementations of our
hosted service moving forward to do
common things like hey I want to DQ
stuff and RabbitMQ or hey I want to sir
break a pattern that's implemented as a
global thing in my app we'll ship those
in the box they're going to come in 2.1
all right so as an example this is what
it looks like it's pretty
straightforward it's an interface with
two methods called start a sink and a
call stop basing all right don't block
in either the by you can block on stop
but don't block and start but the idea
here is that we call start a sink in C
really and we wait for the task to
return and then we move on all right if
you need to start off some type of
background operation you would fire off
a different task or a different thread
in your start a sink and then when the
stop call is made you would then go off
and coordinate shutting that down okay
so you still have to deal with
multi-threaded programming all that type
of stuff you don't get away from that
but now you have a nice hook in the
system for doing that all right kestrel
who loves kestrel come on okay spinning
orchestral is fantastic super super fast
server we wrote it from scratch c-sharp
it runs everywhere but we've never let
you run it directly on the internet if
you are not putting it behind is or
Ingenix we would say sorry you're not
supported so we did a whole bunch of
work in eastern air core to to add
limits to kestrel and then we set them
to recommended levels by default in the
box so that if you ring us up now and
say I'm running kestrel and it's
directly against the internet we will
still support you all right so we've
hardened it what else so what type of
things so we've got like request limits
a maximum number of concurrent
connections and concurrent requests and
then most importantly things like
timeout limits so all the various stages
of requests when their headers sum in
the connection is first made when the
request comes in when the headers are
being parsed the number of headers the
size of the request body how many bytes
per second are being transferred on the
request body how many bytes per second
is the client reading the responses I'm
sending them etc etc we have limits for
all those things now and they're all set
by default in all cases they're set to
limits that are the same as or better
than is all right so you should be good
and you can change them all right there
they're set but they're all fully
documented you can go and change them
all now if you change them to values
less than our defaults then you're on
your own we're not going to support you
quite as much in that case all right we
still do generally recommend that in
most cases you should be putting kestrel
behind some type of reverse proxy
because that's not a full-blown web
server
it's an application server okay but we
have done the work now to add these
limits so if you really really really
need to you can directly expose it now
this is really good for like scenarios
where you're running lots of micro
services and you want them to talk to
each other as fast as possible with the
lowest latency and stuff there's no need
to put them behind anything in those
cases and you can still have your limits
to protect them in that case all right
authentication the auth system in 1x had
some problems
it was completely rebuilt for a spinet
call and we shipped it and then people
started using it and then they used it
in ways we didn't intend and then we
accidentally broke them in 1.1 because
we fixed bugs that people are taking
dependencies on so we went back to the
drawing board and - oh and we worked
with the community especially those who
owned and maintained some of the largest
identity sort of projects and we
redesigned the authentication system so
now you have a single authentication
middleware that sits in the pipeline and
you can figure all your all of your
authentication in services ok we have
authentication handlers that live in the
DI container that you can configure
separately and then they all sort of
participate in the global problem or
solution area of doing authentication
for your app ok it is a breaking change
from one X you can't just take an app
that used orphan 1x change a couple of
packages and then recompile it you will
get compilation errors all right
we moved things around in order to avoid
ambiguity between the old API and the
new API alright so we deprecated and
deleted some properties hanging off HTML
context and we added some new ones all
right and you'll see that there's a very
good doc that talks about all of this
out of the box on good news because I
mean that's good news but breaking
changes are never fun we have now add a
two factor auth support using QR codes
or TOTP in the templates by default so
let's have a look at that because that's
kind of fun to show so if I run this
application this is the one I was using
before I did
select authentication and or when I
created it I can come up to register let
me register a new user without
accidentally hitting whatever key that
was there to have to put in a
ridiculously complex password by default
so I should get in the F
they haven't run my migrations on this
app yet so I get that nice developer EF
migration page I can hit apply
migrations that will set up my database
eventually come on don't fail me now
there go says refresh the page continue
okay so now I am registered I can click
on here to go to my manage thing and we
redesigned the manage account page
because frankly it was butt ugly before
so we did a little bit of work to make
it nice so we have these little pills
over here now they kind of separate the
different things and importantly we have
support for two factor auth in the
template with no further setup required
by default I kind of lied a little bit
of setup is required but it does it's
fully functional without doing anything
so I can hit add all ten to cater app
but you'll note there's something
missing here so I've got my code but I
don't have my QR code I can't scan it
with my phone
alright there's a link here that says to
enable QR code generation please read
our documentation so I did that so
where's the docs though I show it down
that was silly of me let's open it again
currently that FW link goes to a github
issue which isn't particularly good they
need to get that fixed
so I just went to the docs website which
is here and I typed QR in here and look
at that
enabling QR code generation a screen
identity this is for 200 so all I need
to do is grab a JavaScript file and I
need to jump dump that in here and then
I'll get QR code generation so let's do
that I've already downloaded this debit
this javascript file so I'm gonna go to
my downloads folder and the reason we
don't ship this in the templates is
basically just legal reasons we didn't
want to ship some random javascript file
off the internet without doing the full
sort of fidelity that we usually do and
once we put it in vs we have to support
it forever so the plan long-term is that
once we get server-side imaging back in
net core which we hope to do in the next
year then we'll just have the templates
use that to generate you a QR code by
default or if some enterprising
individual in the community wants to
build an amazing c-sharp based QR code
generation library that works on thought
that standard in the next few months
I'll happily include it in the template
and promote your library that would be
awesome but in the meantime I have to
use this javascript file over here QR
code I'm going to drop that into my
dubbed a brute
put it in label just put it straight in
the root there it is QR code and QR code
Minjae yes then if I go over to my pages
folder go into the account folder going
to manage and enable the enable
Authenticator CS HTML which is that page
I was just on there all I have to do now
is add a script block down here that
loads that particular file so let me do
that I'm going to copy and paste it out
of the templates there we go so I load
the file
I'm quite sure why they have this in
here that seems like a throwback doesn't
it
all right so we load the file and then
we go off and we create the de QR code
by pointing at the element that was
already in the template I should also
put a tilde in front of that really all
right so that should be all I have to do
if I go back to my application now and I
hit f5 I now have a QR code so in theory
I could exit out of my presenter timer I
could grab my Authenticator app it's my
Google Authenticator app hit plus scan a
barcode
trust me I'm actually going to scan a
barcode and I'll do this here all right
so now I have a code it's told me my
code for web application 29 is two three
one six hit verify so now I have an able
to factor auth and it's showing me the
recovery codes alright so remember once
you've been able to factor auth use your
phone you're screwed you can't sign in
alright unless you have saved one of
these recovery codes and then you're
able to use a recovery code to reclaim
your applicator your your auth if you do
so so if I was gonna be really clever
I'd take a photo or something of these
now but this is just a throwaway demo
app so and ok so if I click on two
factor auth now you can see that I've
got new buttons because I've configured
it I can turn it back off again or I can
get my recovery codes or get new ones so
let's sign out and we'll sign back in
now that I've got to factor auth and a
Coke in Damien out Damien Edwards comm
hopelessly complicated password alright
so now it's asking me to put in my
authentic ater codes
let me bring up my app it is now changed
to you know how it counts down to the
next one and when you're right there
like a couple seconds away you panic and
then you like you and everybody make a
mistake and then it times out and have
to start all over again alright so now
I've signed in to factor off pretty much
out of the box just a couple lines
to get the QR code and we get that out
of the box now with a spinette cord -
now just incidentally we did have stuff
before in the templates for doing to
factor or the SMS if you recall it
required quite a lot more setup because
you had to enable an SMS provider you'd
like sign up for SendGrid or something
like that write a bunch of code but more
importantly SMS now just isn't
considered quite quite as secure because
if the attacker knows your phone number
they can kind of start mimicking your
phone and like get your SMS is being
sent to them and all types of horrible
things so QR codes and top P are just
generally considered a better approach
you're doing this now so that's why we
do it by default all right what have we
done in Razer I'm not going to talk
about Razer pages that's the next talk
but what else have we done well we now
support c-sharp 7.1 which we didn't
before because we made a mistake in a
spinet called one c-sharp seven came out
but raised our only support of c-sharp
six then we had a bug so we've fit we've
fixed that bug now and you can if you've
opted in to the latest c-sharp features
in your project which is still opt-in
you can get that stuff working in Razer
now you can also automatically inject
content into the head and body elements
of pages now using a tag hopper
component which is a new feature in a
spirit core - well I tagged up a
component is like a tag helper but you
don't use it directly it's a small thing
that looks like a tag helper from a
class point of view but it gets consumed
by other tag helpers that have actually
attached to real tags okay so we have a
head and body tag though they're in the
framework and they're turned on by
default so that you can write it-- a gob
of components that can light up against
the head tag in the body tag essentially
to inject content into your page
automatically all right we have better
support for tag helpers in the tooling
which is nice and we have this whole
thing called razor pages which I'm going
to talk about after this so let's have a
quick look at some of the things in
razor I have to enable I can go ahead
and enable C sharp 7.1 so if I go into
the properties of my application go to
build and I go down to advanced features
I don't know why they hide it in advance
honestly there's all these scary things
with like addresses and stuff but this
is one we want I want to change some
latest major version to latest minor so
the c-sharp team said
point one is their first minor version
ever they've only ever shipped language
versions with major versions of vs this
is the first time they've ever shipped a
version of c-sharp that isn't with a new
major version of vs okay and so rather
than just fast-forward every one to
seven point one they decided that
they're going to require customers to
opt in to the newest minor features
which is fine so I can do that here okay
and now my application will compile
using c-sharp 7.1 if I go to the project
file just to see what it did all it
really did was add this Lang version
thing down here now again I kind of got
bit by the property page there so I'm
just can delete the condition and I'm
just going to put it there alright so
I'm now telling CS proj that I just once
yes reload all I'm telling serious
projects that I just want to use the
latest version of c-sharp the whole time
all right now Razer will honor whatever
you've set and you see as pod file it's
not separate we just read that config
and you can use that now so what type of
things can you do well there is an
interesting feature in c-sharp 7 using
static does anyone use that anyone seen
that no so it allows you to import a
static class as a using like a namespace
and then all of the methods on that
static class now become part of like the
global namespace I thought it was a
little odd I'm like why would you ever
globally import system math and then
just want to call the cosine function
that seems a little silly but with razor
it's actually kind of cool because what
you can do is go into your view imports
and remember view imports are the things
that apply to all razor files in this
folder and everything underneath right
in the Cascade and then you can put
using static in here alright so I could
do system dot math as an example and
then I could go into a razor file so
like my index file and now in here I
could do you know cosine alright so now
I've got the cosine function directly
like it was on my page because it's been
globally imported what it'll probably a
little more useful is that who's ever
created a custom razor base class before
a couple of notes ok so that's fine
right you can create item usually you
end up doing that to put utility methods
and stuff on it so you don't have to
inject it everywhere well with this
feature you can just create a static as
long as the method you have at a static
too
put them in a static class put one line
in your viewing ports and now they're in
every single file in your application
you have to change the base class which
we know can introduce sort of ball of
mud type scenarios where now you've got
a different base class and like in
changing it the future can be
problematic because if we change our
base class in 2.1 we could break you and
like that's not a good thing so I think
this is a much cleaner way of like
adding Universal helper methods to all
of your razor files so that's a really
really cool feature a way to use that
cool feature in c-sharp inside razor now
which I thought was kind of nice okay
let me bit quickly build an eye tag of a
component and then we will I finish up
so I'm going to add a folder and we'll
call it tag helpers because we want to
be tidy and then in here I will add not
that in here I'll add a class and we'll
call it the console hello tag help
component I should have chosen a smaller
name it would have been easier to type
all right tag helper component is what I
derived from let me bring that in it
looks very much like a tag hopper I can
override process which is what I'm gonna
do okay and then in here I'm just gonna
say if context I'm gonna say actually
I'm going to say if string dot equals
context tag name so I find in the body
team if I'm in the body and I'll just do
a ordinal in dog taste so that it's case
insensitive if I am in the body tag I
want to inject a little bit of
JavaScript at the bottom of the page all
right so you can already do stuff in tag
helpers where rather than having to read
all the content and when you played it
you just want to put something in the
beginning I'll put something at the
bottom so I can do that here output dot
post
okay so post content or post element
well I'm gonna target the body tags I
want it after the content in the body
tag but before the closing body tag so
post content dot append HTML and then
I'll just hard code JavaScript tag in
here and we'll say hello out on the
console console you log and I'll say
hello from and I'll make this a
templated string
let's use all the C sharp features and
I'll do name of because that's a great
feature as well and we'll do console
hello hello did you know okay set builds
doesn't it yes shift f6 build started
come on quicker please I'm running out
of time excellent startup CS now I just
have to tell the system about it well
that's easy I just have to add it to the
DI container we just find them so add a
transient I tagged help a component
bring that in and it was called console
hello tag helper component component
alright done I put it in di let me go
back to my page I'll bring up the
console with f12 and I'll hit f5 now
it's gonna automatically fail because I
have to relaunch it apparently let's do
that control f5 to launch the app bring
up the console from quick and then right
down the bottom here you can see now I
have my hello from console helper
console hello tag hold the component so
what's that useful form well we use that
primarily for telemetry and diagnostics
types applicator libraries so
application insights when it gets lit up
in Asia by default like you saw me doing
in the debugger before we also do that
now so now so when you deploy this to
air 2 as your app service you can get
that feature running in there we add
JavaScript as part of the azure tracking
we can track page views for you without
you having to do anything to your
application ok really kind of nice
I know people used to do that type of
stuff in system web using like a
response filter and you'd look at the
outgoing stream and you would like look
for the end of the HTML tag and then you
would put stuff horrible this is much
much much easier
super-nice improvement so the actual
integration to finish automatic as your
app service diagnostics if you deploy a
spear core to - as your app service the
app service Diagnostics blade where you
can turn on application logging it just
works now you don't have to add packages
or call methods it just works ok and you
can get stream logging and all that
stuff if you want to get application
insights running no code required you
get this banner that says click here to
turn on application insights for this
asp.net core application you click it
you say yes use this application
insights resource or create a new one
restarts the app and now app insight is
running in your app again no packages to
add no config to add no instrumentation
key to find nothing it's just all
automatic and it's running in your
application
in Asia very very nice all right lastly
we do have a spinet called docker images
who's using docker okay please make sure
you use the HP net core images not the
dotnet core images okay a spoon air core
images are pre-configured to make a
spinet core work the.net core ones
aren't
alright so please use those ones and
they've all been updated we really want
to help customers get to 200 now now the
two hours out and has unlocked a lot of
things we want you to get onto to very
quickly to that end later this year
you'll see us release the windows
compact pack for that we'll add back to
dotnet core think when you're on Windows
things that you might be relying on that
are keeping you on debt framework namely
system directory services if you're
calling out to LDAP or Active Directory
system dot drawing if you need to do
server-side imaging and system dot
service process if you want to do
Windows service hosting for self hosted
applications you'll see that get
released later this year hopefully that
will help a lot of customers move off
dotnet framework on to dotnet core if
they're looking for the benefits of
dotnet core lastly a spin of course
signal art which I know a lot of people
are waiting for we will have an alpha of
that out in the next month that you'll
be able to run on top of to own so that
you can start at least giving us
feedback on the new signal arm but the
actual release of signaler will not come
until they spin at core 2.1 okay which
we're planning right now so if you want
to get involved in the next version if
you're really at the bleeding edge jump
on the github go look at the stuff that
we're talking about now the stuff that
we're coding and give us feedback super
super early thank you that was an
overview of a spinet court or if you
want to see what razer pages is about
stick around or i'm going into room 3 i
think it is to talk about Razer pages
next otherwise please try to ask them
their core two and enjoy the rest of the
conference thank you
[Applause]